at this point you probably know there's
absolute chaos going on in canada the
trucker convoy the freedom protest they
made their way to ottawa and they are
protesting vaccine and mass mandates
they simply are saying 90 of truckers
are vaccinated we just want you to leave
our citizens alone now of course the
government they had two choices they
could simply say you have a right to
protest we hear you maybe we'll make
some changes based on what our citizens
want or they can become abrasive they
can actually push back that's exactly
what they're doing but they're not
actually using anything that you would
expect in their response they're not
using the rule of law they're not using
the police force instead what they are
doing is they are waging an all-out war
on these protests they've actually
invoked the emergency act to wartime
measure that if somebody was coming to
attack canada
then they would use these measures and
that's exactly what they're doing here's
a video of the government openly
admitting that they're freezing bank
accounts that they are going after their
citizens that whether you are
participating in the actual protest or
you simply are a passive donator to the
cause if you believe in freedom and you
donated more than 25 they're coming
after you as well listen to them say it
for themselves so you're confirming that
accounts have been frozen both personal
and corporate but you're not releasing
the information and the actual follow-up
is
i'm just wondering whether the bank
accounts will be targeted of individuals
who donated to the give sengo and the
gofundme campaigns are they considered
designated people under the emergencies
act meaning that their credit cards
could be cut and financial services are
targeting them as well
okay so
the names of both individuals and
entities
as well as crypto wallets
have been shared by the rcmp
with financial institutions
and accounts have been frozen
and more accounts will be frozen
uh
crowdfunding platforms and payment
service providers have started the
registration process
with
fintrac
uh in terms of the specifics on whose
accounts are being frozen
you now
have
the regulations
the financial service providers have
those regulations as well
and they working with law enforcement
will be making the operational decisions
this is absolute chaos what the hell is
going on canada is supposedly a liberal
democracy but they're being quite
abrasive overreaching an authoritarian
with their citizens now here we have a
quote that explains exactly what's going
on and why you should be worried about
this the censorship of money is
something we see in an authoritarian
country not one like canada regardless
of my views on the protest freezing
accounts for political reasons is a big
big slippery slope felipe jet coming out
and explaining exactly what the problem
is if you start this game you then
empower political parties to go after
anyone who pushes back against their
views if all of a sudden you now give
this power to the other political party
is that really what you want do you want
politicians who are able to actually go
after you because you simply disagree
with their ideas it's a big big slippery
slope we've got this tweet here from
jordan who's got a great way of putting
it just so you're aware of the current
situation in canada the regime under
justin trudeau is rounding up and
persecuting citizens for the act of
donating to a peaceful protest and
waging economic warfare against
pro-freedom protesters freezing their
assets for the act of wrong think now
that sounds crazy and it literally
sounds like it couldn't be possible
that's exactly what's happening in
canada right now and so if we go back
where did justin trudeau the prime
minister of canada lose his way he's got
a tweet from 2012 that said when a
government starts trying to cancel
dissent or avoid dissent is when is
rapidly losing its moral authority to
govern well that's exactly what canada's
doing right now
what moral authority do they have to
govern at this point this is absurd the
international community is up in arms
what canada is doing should be a huge
concern for all of us let me put it a
different way for you yesterday i
tweeted the following wow china is
freezing dissidents bank accounts and
threatening citizens who express their
freedom of speech oh wait sorry it's
canada not china
canada a liberal democracy is doing this
are canadians free
or do they live in authoritarian
government regime
that's the question people start asking
themselves and here's the worst part
freezing someone's bank account is bad
enough
but this isn't about economics this
isn't about mandates
this is absolute all-out warfare against
citizens here's a perfect example this
official ottawa account said attention
animal owners at the demonstration if
you're unable to care for your animal as
a result of enforcement actions your
animal will be placed in protective care
for eight days at your cost after eight
days if arrangements are not made
your animal will be considered
relinquished that's the equivalent of
the mob saying something like
be a damn shame if something happened to
your pet this is just threats
this is literally getting out of hand at
some point all evil needs to do to
propagate itself is for good men to stay
silent if you're watching this and you
disagree
i believe it's your duty to say
something ultimately governments listen
to their citizens if enough people push
back if enough people voice their
opinion they'll stop they'll knock it
off because if they don't people will
use their voice in the voting booth and
they'll vote these morons out of office